JOE CREATED AND MAYBE HE'LL STO
IT.
PETER DUCEY, GREAT TO SEE YOU
PAIR A TIER WITH REACTION FORME
WHITE HOUSE CHIEF OF STAFF,
FORMER WHITE HOUSE PRESS
SECRETARY HIMSELF AND FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR ARI FLEISCHER.
I AM LISTENING TO THESE ANSWERS
THE REASON WE ARE NOT COVID
TESTING ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS IS
BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT GOING TO BE
HERE VERY LONG.
OR GIVING THEM REQUEST FORMS TO
SHOW UP, THEY'RE NOT EVEN
MANDATORY DATES TO SHOW UP IN
COURT.
WE REQUEST YOU SHOW UP ON THIS
DATE, BUT WE'RE NOT GOING TO
FORCE YOU TO SHOW UP RIGHT NOW,
ARI, I HAVE A FUNNY FEELING
NOBODY IS GOING TO SHOW UP.
>> A FUNNY FEELING GREAT AND
ACCURATE FEELING.
TODAY IS ONE OF THE MOST
DISTRESSING LOWEST MOMENTS I
HAVE EVER SEEN IN THE UNITED
STATES GOVERNMENT.
EVERYTHING THAT JOE BIDEN SAID
TODAY ABOUT THIS IS NOT THE
AMERICAN WAY, THAT THIS IS A
TRAGEDY, THAT THIS IS NOT HOW
PEOPLE SHOULD ACT.
EVERYTHING HE SAID TODAY SHOULD
HAVE BEEN SAID ABOUT THOSE THAT
ARE TRYING TO ENTER AMERICA
ILLEGALLY, AND NOT ABOUT THE
PEOPLE WHO WERE DOING THEIR JOB
AND ENFORCING AMERICA'S LAWS.
THIS IS A PERFECT ILLUSTRATION
OF HOW THE DEMOCRATS LED BY JOE
BIDEN ARE ANTI- POLICE.
EVERYWHERE AND EVERYWHERE PAIR
THAT'S A MESSAGE TODAY, DON'T
ENFORCE AMERICA'S LAWS.
WHEN YOU SEE SOMEBODY BREAKING
INTO OUR COUNTRY, LET THEM IN.
HE'S ALSO SEEN TO POLICE FORCES
EVERYWHERE, AND WARHORSE PATROLS
.
ANYBODY ON BOURBON STREET, THEY
HAVE FORCE PATROLS THERE ALL TH
TIME.
IS THAT SOMEHOW INHUMANE, IT'S
TO DETER PEOPLE FROM COMING INT
THE COUNTRY BUT THE RESULT OF
JOE BIDEN'S POLICIES IS GOING T
INVITE MANY MORE PEOPLE INTO TH
COUNTRY.
THIS IS OPEN BORDERS AT ITS
WORST ENCOURAGED BY THE
PRESIDENT BY THE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES PART.
>> PICK A FEW WISHES.
WE ACHIEVED ENERGY INDEPENDENCE
FOR THE FIRST TIME IN 75 YEARS,
FOR NATIONAL SECURITY REASONS
IT'S GREAT, WE DON'T HAVE TO AS
COUNTRIES THAT HATE US TO IMPOR
OIL, WE DIDN'T IMPORT ANY OIL
FROM SAUDI ARABIA IN THE FINAL
MONTHS OF THE TRUMPET
MINISTRATION.
WE DON'T HAVE TO CARE ABOUT WHA
HAPPENS IN THE STREETS OF HORMU
WHERE IRAN PLAYS A LOT OF GAMES
WITH THE WORLD'S OIL SUPPLY, A
THIRD OF WHICH COMES THROUGH
THERE.
AND THEN, NOW JOE IS BEGGING
OPEC TO INCREASE PRODUCTION.
WHY DOESN'T HE GO BACK TO TRUMP
'S POLICIES OF ENERGY
INDEPENDENCE LIKE HE COULD GO
BACK TO TRUMP'S POLICIES ON THE
BORDER, LIKE HE COULD GO BACK T
TRUMP'S POLICIES ON ANTIBODIES
AND NOT ABANDONING AMERICANS IN
AFGHANISTAN?
>> BECAUSE THEY DON'T WANT TO.
IT'S NOT WHO THEY ARE.
I DON'T THINK THEY CARE ABOUT
SOVEREIGNTY.
I DON'T THINK THEY ACTUALLY CAR
ABOUT BORDERS.
THIS IS WHO THEY ARE.
AND EVERY ONCE IN A WHILE, THEI
COMPETENCY OR THEIR INCOMPETENC
COMES TO LIGHT.
YOU MENTIONED BEFORE, JOE BIDEN
PLAYING THE BLAME GAME.
HE BLAMES THE BORDER PATROL FOR
MISTREATING ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS.
HE BLAMES TRUMP FOR THE TALIBAN
BEING IN POWER.
HE EVEN BLAMES HIS STAFF ARE NO
CALLING ON CERTAIN REPORTERS
THAT HE DOESN'T WANT TO CALL ON.
UNLIKE TRUMKA MAY JOSÉ I'M NOT
CALLING ON YOU BECAUSE I THINK
YOU'RE A LIAR, HE JUST BLAMES
OTHER PEOPLE.
HERE IS MY POINT.
HE HAS THE OPINIONS ON THESE
ISSUES.
YOU KNOW THAT BIDEN RESCINDED,
AND I JUST WROTE A LIST OF LIKE
TEN THINGS IN A SECOND DURING
THE MONOLOGUE HE RESCINDED THE
LAW, HE RESCINDED ZERO TOLERANCE
, HE PRESENTED THE
PARIS AGREEMENT, HE RESCINDED
KEYSTONE, HE RESCINDED THE
POLICY ON TRANSGENDER IN THE
MILITARY.
THEY HAVE THIS VIEW OF AMERICA
THAT IS NOT THE VIEW THAT MOST
PEOPLE IN THIS COUNTRY HAVE.
THE PROBLEM THAT BIDEN HAS NOW
IS THAT WHEN BECAUSE HE RAN AS
THIS GUY OF COMPETENCY COMMIT
WHEN THIS MESS ON THE BORDER
COMES TO LIGHT BECAUSE THEY
DON'T CARE IF HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE POUR OVER
THE BORDER, BUT EVERY ONCE IN A
WHILE THEY'VE GOT A REALLY BAD
CAMERA SHOTS, AND THEY'VE GOT
15,000 HAITIANS UNDER A BRIDGE
AND PEOPLE START WONDERING, WAI
A MINUTE, THIS GUY ISN'T VERY
COMPETENT, THEY SEE WHAT HAPPEN
IN AFGHANISTAN, 13 SERVICE
PEOPLE ARE KILLED TRAGICALLY.
WAIT A MINUTE.
THIS GUY IS INCOMPETENT AND THA
YOU HAVE DEMOCRATS WHO USUALLY
DON'T AGREE WITH US ON THE
BORDER OR OUR FOREIGN POLICY, A
CHUNK OF THOSE PEOPLE ARE SAYIN
THIS GUY IS NOT COMPETENT RIGHT
THAT'S WHY HIS NUMBERS ARE
SINKING.
>>Sean: I KNOW A LOT OF PEOPLE
IN THE MEDIA WOULD FEIGN OUTRAG
OVER TRUMPS MEAN TWEETING PAIR
THEY DIDN'T LIKE IT.
DONALD TRUMP WOULD NEVER ABANDO
AMERICANS FREIGHT HE WOULDN'T
HAVE GIVEN UP ENERGY
INDEPENDENCE DONALD TRUMP WOULD
GIVE IT WE HAD A 25 YEAR LOW IN
TERMS OF ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS
COMING INTO THE COUNTRY.
WE DIDN'T HAVE A SINGLE AMERICA
KILLED IN AFGHANISTAN FOR 18
MONTHS UNDER HIS POLICIES.
THEY BELIEVED HE WOULD KILL HIM.
I DON'T SAY THAT IS A DETERRENT
FACTOR WITH JOE BIDEN.
>> THAT'S EXACTLY IT.
DONALD TRUMP WAS RUDE WHEN HE
WANTED TO BE RUDE, HE COULD BE
BULL IN THE CHINA SHOP AND EVER
TIME HE WENT, HE BROUGHT A NEW
CHINA SHOP WITH HIM.
BUT HE KEPT THE ATTENTION HE
CHANGE THE WAY WE DID BUSINESS
AND HE WAS TREMENDOUSLY
EFFECTIVE ACROSS-THE-BOARD.
LOWEST POVERTY RATE SINCE 1959,
CHINA CHANGING ITS BEHAVIOR.
NO NEW WARS STARTED, THAT'S
BECAUSE OF POLICY AND THAT'S WH
I'M A POLICY FIRST PERSON.
I DON'T CARE IF JOE BIDEN TWEET
OR DOESN'T TWEET, IT'S NOT
WHAT'S RELEVANT TO HOW YOU
PROTECT AMERICA OR ENFORCE
AMERICA'S LAW, RULE AMERICANS
BORDER.
POLICY MATTERS.
WHEN IT COMES TO POLICY, JOE
BIDEN IS SHOWING HE IS NOT UP
FOR THE JOB.
HIS JUDGMENT IS WRONG, AND HE'S
A LIBERAL AS LIBERAL AS IT GETS
AND HE IS TRYING TO SHOW THROUG
THE LEFT-WING WISHLIST RED.
>> WILL DONALD TRUMP TRY TO COM
BACK?
>> I THINK ALMOST CERTAINLY HE
IS GOING TO RUN AGAIN.
BUT LOOK, JOE BIDEN, YOU BECOME
A FAILURE WHEN YOU START BLAMIN
OTHERS FOR YOUR OWN MISTAKES
POLICY IS WHO YOU ARE.
ARI IS RIGHT AND THE POLICIES O
JOE BIDEN IS WHAT WILL AND DO
HIM.
IS GOING TO RUN AND WE WILL HAV
A BIG RACE UPCOMING IN 2024, BU
WE WILL WORRY ABOUT 2020 TO NEXT
.
>> I WILL TELL YOU THIS, I THIN
PEOPLE WILL BE LESS CONCERNED
ABOUT THE TWEETS AND MORE
CONCERNED ABOUT BEING COMPETENT
IN KNOWING WHAT DAY OF THE WEEK
IT IS.
JUST MY GUESS.
I NEVER WOULD HAVE GUESSED WE
WOULD ABANDON AMERICANS AND HAV
THIS DISASTER AT THE BORDER.
I NEVER THOUGHT WE'D